>> For those who don't know me, I'm Mark.
I'm part of the @Google team.
I have to admit, I was a little bit hesitant
about today's talk.
I'm one of these people who thinks of computer
gamers as these sort of
teenaged troglodytes who heroically contribute
to the obesity crisis
rather than sort of as deeply social people
but I'm here to be proved
wrong, which is great.
So welcome, of course, Tom Chatfield who is
here to prove me wrong.
Tom has written this book Fun, Inc., and is
going to tell us all about
the social and business side of gaming, so
please welcome him.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM CHATFIELD: Thank you for having me.
I've been to -- I've written a book that covers
all sorts of different
aspects of gaming, that talks about the social
aspects of gaming, that
talks about the business aspects of gaming,
that talks about even games
in artistic terms.
But I wanted to talk with something specific.
One of the things that I think is one of the
most interesting key
points and key ways of thinking about games
in general -- video games
in particular -- which is, games as learning
engines, games as learning
experiences.
I've called it the fail epic.
Partly because I think one of the key aspects
of games is the way that
they transform our attitude towards failure,
the idea of failure, with
that, the idea of success.
I think there are really two key points about
all games which underpin
the fact that games have a history as old
as civilization.
In the first place, games in many ways, precede
civilization.
And this is the fact that games touch something
very fundamental in us
by being both concentrated kinds of experience
and safe kinds of
experience.
So quintessential games, historically, were
to do with warfare and to
do with social hierarchy.
That these were safe, concentrated, repetitive
ways of honing absolutely
vital skills, but skills that would get you
killed if you tried to
practice them by just going out and doing
them.
So games offer a safe, concentrated environment
and the structure of
incentives and rewards to keep people doing
these things and
practicing, getting better at these absolutely
vital skills.
And in many ways, computer games are intensification
of this, of the
key things they offer to games in general
is the kind of feedback you
get is far, far more rapid and the kind of
control that you have over
the experience that you get from it is far,
far more precise than
anything we've seen before.
Start off with a cheerful quote from Samuel
Beckett.
This really is about the idea of recasting
failure, not as an absolute
-- you failed, therefore it's all over.
It's about recasting failure as something
that you do better.
It's a step on the way to success.
And this, I think, gets at one of the key
points about all games which
is transforming failure, I think video games
are doing this in sort of
a particularly intense and remarkable way.
A slightly different quote.
I'm not quite sure what metric Woody Allen
was using to arrive at his
statistic.
But I think he's hit on something there, by
far the most common form of
failure is not trying.
By far the most common form of failure is
not being prepared to engage
in a task in the first place, because it's
intimidating, because of the
risk of censure.
Because it's -- if you're worried about how
something will go, if the
result is something that scares you, you're
unlikely to brave it or
take it on.
Now, we're talking about video games as learning
engines.
I'm not talking about taking video games and
putting them into
classrooms.
It's not about using Pac-Man to teach Spanish.
It's not about saying that everyone in a history
class ought to be
playing Age of Empires in order to learn about
history.
I think that kind of argument misses the point
because what games are
doing is showing us some very powerful, underlying
human principles
about learning and about structures of learning.
And what's been remarkable over the 50-odd
years that computer games
have existed is that they haven't stood still,
they didn't just arrive
in the world as addictive, compelling, fully-formed
activities.
They began as one thing, and then because
of commercial and social
pressures, they have followed an incredibly
rapid evolutionary curve,
next to their authors, in terms of engaging
people, in terms of
incrementally improving the kind of engagement
they offer.
And I want to look at the underlying lessons
that come from it.
First of all, talk a little bit about traditional
learning and
training.
Now, this is a bit of a cliche to say that
traditional learning and
training has stood still for sort of hundreds
of years.
It's certainly true that we have a very schizophrenic
attitude towards
play and towards play-like activities.
And we absolutely accept that up to the ages
of 5 or 6 the bulk of the
way that people learn about the world around
them is by sort of
playful, unstructured or game-like activities
and then suddenly we do a
switch.
We insist that the hard work begins.
And we begin what you could sum up as a rather
linear, straight-forward
process of learning.
And there have been plenty of efforts to change
this to a form to
introduce group work, a lot of these have
been very effective.
But they haven't really, I think, had underlying
principles rooted in
empirical study, what people are actually
like.
So I want to talk about a few of the sort
of cliche limitations of
traditional attitudes towards learning approach.
There we have a traditional learning scene.
So first thing is few failures; they're not
experimental.
Now I don't mean that people aren't failing.
In fact, if you think of learning as being
something that's truly
tested by what it does for the weakest members
of the group, and if you
imagine a weak 6- or 7-year old struggling
to learn to read a passage
in fact, their experience in traditional lesson
is likely to be almost
entirely composed of failure.
There will probably be three or four decisive
failures, at which point
someone is very likely to give up.
What it isn't is experimental, and what they're
not being given is
opportunities to fail in a positive way.
They will simply try to stumble through a
few sentences, stop, and
really be able to go no further.
There's no control they have over it.
And it makes the second point, that there's
a lot of censure associated
with this kind of failure.
It's pain not gain from these sorts of things.
When confronted the sheet they're supposed
to be reading, and words
don't make sense to them in the classroom,
there is humiliation.
There is frustration.
There's a big turn off.
There's not really that much else.
And the feedback is very slow.
I think it's still true especially for weaker
people that often when
some people sit down to their duty the first
or second time they
actually sat for an exam, the feedback they
get takes a long time to
come.
It can seem very distant from what they're
doing and seem very
incomprehensible and threatening.
And I think this applies just as much to a
lot of training
environments, implicitly or explicitly, that
feedback is delivered in
big, ugly, rather unpleasant lumps.
And there's little personal investment.
By that I mean that someone doesn't have much
control over the process
they're going through.
If you imagine a person reading the textbook,
it's like the books
dumped on your desk -- work through it.
You don't really have much of an option to
choose anything to this
process.
You will submit to it.
You may succeed.
You may master it; you may not.
But really, it puts an enormous onus on teaching
you and on your
support structures, and an enormous onus on
your resourcefulness, but
it's not something you feel you can own in
any sort of a crucial way.
Part and central to this is, I think largely
true of most conventional training and teaching
that there is one thing that you're doing
at a time in front of you on the desk, and
task at the moment.
You may switch to another, but there's a single
path through it, and you
know with lots of people with a whole spectrum
of abilities, it's
almost a given that a lot of people will let
down by one way or nothing.
And re-connected to that history and progress,
so we've got our
person sitting down in a classroom studying
a piece of reading.
Now that teacher knows very well what the
syllabus is and probably has
a very good idea of where all their peoples
sit on the spectrum of are
they going to pass this exam at the end the
term.
But they don't really know much about this
at all.
They have very, very little grasp, even the
good ones, of where they
need to be eventually, of how long along that
path they are, and of
where they've come from.
They might have a few scattered results and
grades, but really -- and
again, I'd say you get this in training environments
as well, people
don't often have a precise grip on where they
need to be in the future
-- in a month, in two months, in three months'
time or any sense of
exactly how far in the year I've done this
or I've done that.
And this leads to limited peer relationships.
By which I mean, people tend to be very aware
of where they are on a
hierarchy, compared to people around them
in the classroom.
The absolutely sure that you know by the age
of 6 or 7, someone's quite
aware of where they sit in the pecking order
of who is the top and who
the middle and who is the bottom.
But you don't have much insight into the process
that's going on with
your colleagues, particularly in the classroom,
sitting around you
writing away.
You have no sense of their method till it
pops out at the end.
Your interactions with the relationship, tends
to be limited to, if you
like, competition and worry.
Now video games -- and this is what I thought
about the trajectory
of games.
Cause in the beginning games were a bit like
that.
Yes, when computer games arrived -- I suppose
Space War is the first
true video game.
They were instantly much more exciting and
accessible than pretty much
anything that had ever happened on a computer
before in terms of
sitting down and using them.
At the same time, they were designed by experts
for experts.
They were designed largely by male geeks for
other male geeks.
Even Space Invaders, a very simple game in
some ways, is very, very
harsh.
It's very, very unforgiving.
It's frankly very, very difficult.
You have to invest quite a lot in it to get
anywhere.
You die and you lose your lives.
That's it.
It's all over.
You got to start again.
I mean, Asteroids is an absolute nightmare
trying to get anywhere on
that.
These early games, they deserve their reputation
as a niche activity
for teenaged boys who didn't much like the
light because they were so
difficult in so many ways.
In many ways, learning to master one of these
games was a traditional
learning experience.
You had to work at it and some people did.
Some people invested hugely in it.
But that's where they began.
And if they just stayed there, [INAUDIBLE]
people said things teenaged
boys, get into them it is a bit of a geek
and then you grow out of
them, you hope.
In fact,
[PAUSE]
what happened is that games completely transformed
themselves over 30,
40, 50 years, and staggeringly transformed
themselves.
I think it's safe to say that electronic games
are now the world's
largest and fastest growing form of mass participation.
And I believe the largest mass participation
we've ever known in
history, the word "games" expanded hugely
to cover a vast spectrum of
activities.
But I think that there's something to do with
learning that underlies
almost all the games in the world at the moment,
and that is something
that is evolved through basically the work
of trying to make more
money, if you like.
Trying to get more people interested in them.
You got the Space Invaders and a certain kind
of person with a certain
slightly fanatical bent would enjoy playing
it and will try to get high
scores, but you're missing out on a huge section
of the market.
And over time, people have tried to bring
in more and more different
kinds of player.
This obviously is a very nice Flying Mount,
from I think it's a
forthcoming Flying Mount.
I think that's going to be in Cataclysms.
I don't think you can get those yet.
But that's a very nice reward at the end game
of World of Warcraft.
And you probably know to get to the end game
of Warcraft, not many
players achieve that, but it's about 12 million
people playing the game
worldwide, very few of them will make it through
to any really
high-level ranges.
And yet people keep playing, there are 12
million people playing this.
And that's because, in many ways, the game
has replaced the word fail
with a rather different idea.
And that is not yet succeeded.
By which I mean that the idea of fail at something
-- something
censorious, something dreadful, something
that puts you off so that
80 percent of you don't turn up, as it were.
80 percent of the world wouldn't bother turning
up to play video games
in the first place, it's so alienating.
That's been replaced with the recognition
that you can come up with
things that different players will do.
Richard Bath, among others, have talked about
four different player
types which covers pretty much the whole spectrum
of human tendencies:
People who want to explore, people who want
to achieve, people who want
to communicate, that sort of thing.
But what we see -- I think Warcraft is a good
example because it's so
good at combining all the lessons of games
from the last 40 or
50 years.
So I want to talk through a little bit about
what it does that is
drawing and holding in so many different kinds
of people and giving
them the sense when they're playing that even
though most of them are
never going to make it into a raid, they're
never going to get Twin
Blades, they're never going to, you know,
get to the real high-end
content.
It doesn't feel like failure.
In many ways it's exciting for them that there
are people who are doing
that because they've got other stuff to do
which they find rewarding.
And the interesting thing is, the underpinning
of this, and there we have one of the latest
versions of this, the idea of achievements,
which
self-evidently suck in thousands and thousands
of human hours around
the world.
But what we got is the fact everyone who is
playing Warcraft is really training for one
thing.
They're training to control a character, and
click on a whole spectrum
of different abilities and equip different
items in order to make their
little character kill stuff.
That's all they're training to do.
We lose sight of that because there's such
an incredibly elaborate
network that is going on.
When in fact, we've been trained to do this
one thing and they've been
trained to do it incredibly well.
In terms of -- imagine a driving test.
Now the kind of training you get from Warcraft
is not like learning to
drive a car.
It's like learning to race an F-1 race.
The level of skill that people are attaining
from what the game puts
them through, the kind of training they voluntarily
submit to, indeed
that they pay for, gets people to an incredible
level of sophistication
and expertise.
People are very, very, very good at this game.
Lots of them, even somewhat bad at this game,
is very good at this
game.
It's incredibly good at getting people to
put in hours of doing
basically, which is hitting a ball with the
sword.
And -- it does this because it offers so many
different ways to people
of making their activity feel like an incremental
success, a
incremental progress.
First of all, we've got characters at level
70 characters, at the top
there.
And a little number that you make go up with
an experience bar.
Everything you do is contributing towards
this number going up.
It's a lovely sense of purpose.
At the same time, there's your reputation.
You do stuff in different factions in the
games, you get a little
reputation here.
You gain a bit of reputation there.
You're more welcome in the city.
You get better prices in that city.
At the same time, there's player versus player,
if you want to PvP
serve, beat other people up and get different
items.
At the same time, there's gear.
There's this tantalizing random element, every
time you attack a morph,
it's going to drop something with a chance
of it being really, really, really awesome.
And this is an amazing book, it was perfected
[INAUDIBLE] this in the
Diablo series of games.
And whole Warcraft.
This is the very, very powerful incentive
to people to just kill that
next bore and see if it happens to drop a
blue item.
Achievements -- as I said this is possibly
the pièce de la résistance
of the Warcraft world.
By giving people an arbitrary task to do and
then allowing them to wear a title that says
I've done that, I'm an explorer.
I've been everywhere.
You allow them to just do random stuff that
wasn't anywhere else and
wear it like a badge of pride in the community.
And that of course is about social studies.
It's absolutely crucial at that everybody's
in this world together, you
can look at each other.
You are looking at each other all the time.
And it's this that validates these achievements.
It's this context that really gives them meaning,
and quite astonishing
value to people because your peers see everything
you do.
And you in turn are excited by seeing people
at the top level by seeing
what could happen.
There's customizations, you have an enormous
and increasing amount of
control over your avatar.
And that means you really come to own it.
If you're bored, you can just go and get a
haircut.
My wife is a doctor, and she spends quite
an amount of time in the game
collecting an entire set of items with the
moniker of a physician.
So she can go around wearing a complete of
a physician set, and she's a
healer, in the game and in life.
And there's many paths.
You're thrown into this game, and it's the
one game world, but it's a
very big and flexible world.
You can choose many different classes.
You can have many different Orcs.
You can explore and you're rewarded for doing
each of these things.
Everything is validated.
Everything is a form of progress.
You want to chat to people, you want to form
a guild, you want to tag
along with raids, fine.
You want to go around causing grief, fine.
If you want to go around ganking people, that's
okay.
Possibly.
You -- it adapts to people.
And it never stands still whilst it gathers
a tremendous amount of
data, something which I don't need to tell
people here about.
And this data is establishing a path because
-- and this data, this
information that's really been driving the
industry forward, at what I
would say is the pretty [INAUDIBLE].
To come from Space Invaders -- bip, bip, bip
-- 20 nerdy men interested
in getting five points, to something which
can hold the attention for
thousands of hours of 12 million people around
the world, or [inaudible], 100 billion users
or something like Zynga's casual games
with close to 200 million users.
This is absolutely staggering, staggering
achievement in finding out
what it is that gets people doing something,
and keep them doing it,
and wanting to improve.
And it's I think what underlies it, is taking
all the things that
would put them off and just loosely boosting
instead their investment
in making all sorts of different kinds of
progress, making energy.
What does all this mean, then?
I could talk in generalities about what -- as
I said at the start, it's
not about putting Pac-Man into the classrooms.
It's not about saying, therefore, everyone
in a Spanish class ought to
play Warcraft.
This is absolute rubbish.
It's about recognizing what the underlying
principles are.
First of all, this is where I think games
show us a different way of
thinking about people, due to traditional
learning and training
structure.
Failures should be frequent, recurrent, recognized,
and free of stigma.
You should not be failing three or four times
in an hour a test and giving up.
You should be not succeeding 20 times in the
space of a minute, and
still having a bit of recognition for that,
getting something for that.
And just doing it again.
Take a wonderful game on the Playstation 3
called Flower, by
Jenova Chen and thatgamecompany.
And this is -- it's not a perfect game but
what it is I think is a
wonderful way of recasting failure as something
triumphant and
personal, because you control it by moving,
the weed and moving the
control around [INAUDIBLE] around, and you
have to pick up other flower
petals.
And when you start playing this game, as some
of you may know, it's
almost impossible to control the thing.
You're -- wind is blowing and the flower petal,
you can spend about 50
times trying to pick up other petals on the
ground, swooping around
with the control pad, and it's really very,
very difficult.
But you don't throw the control across the
room.
You fail 50 times within about the space of
about two minutes.
And you pick up your first petal, and then
you start to move, and then
you start to do other stuff.
And as a bit of spatial training, training
someone who's never
interacted with a computer before, there are
plenty of people like this
in the world, just moving something around
to control something
beautiful on a screen is a very, very good
way of lowering the bearings
of entry, of teaching people how to access
this electronic world and
the reason I think that people are unafraid
to fail 50 times in two
minutes in this game is that there is no stigma
attached.
That the experience is not punishing you for
not yet succeeding.
It's merely enticing you with graphics, with
sounds.
It uses principles of flow as well, so it
adapts to your own way
of doing things.
And really, it's a completely different way
of thinking about a problem
and a skill set.
It draws you on.
Second, progress should be clear and cumulative,
with multiple paths
and show increments.
What I'm talking about here is what I was
saying about a person sitting
in a classroom, desperately trying to read
through a passage with
absolutely no idea what this means in the
context of a GCSE or a term
or even a letter.
Now what you can do in games, for instance,
to take World of Warcraft
again, first time you play the game, you've
got all the numbers, I was
talking about all your level and everything
like that, and you are
plunked in the middle of cities.
Cities like [INAUDIBLE], when you're surrounded
by people who have been
playing the game for thousands of hours surrounded
by amazing items.
You can wander as a level five character into
a level 55 area, and look
at the absolute terrifying monsters in there.
And people do do this, and this is about knowing
where you're going.
The entire thing is laid out for you in tiny
increments.
You can see exactly where you'll be at level
55 or level 60 or level
65, you can see and start to appreciate what
the end game loot will
look like, what it might look like.
And this is tremendously incentivizing.
You can see exactly where you've come from
and measure your progress
but all of the criteria is listed, everything
from level reputation, you
take ownership of all of it, you see precisely
where you are on the
scale.
And this really gives people a tremendous
sense of choosing where they
want to be, and of choosing to invest the
activities.
It's like going back to the analogy of the
school.
Someone in a math class struggling to learn
about differential
equations, having free to access at any moment
post-graduate level
mathematics, imagining numbers, all sorts
of other highly advanced
theories and realizing in the very structure
of the set-up that what
they're doing now in their very basic way
is on a spectrum with these
other amazing things.
You see yourself in context and that is enormously
empowering for
people to understand exactly how far they've
progressed on the same
virtual scale towards where they want to be
and towards where they
might be.
Not everybody gets to the end game of Warcraft,
but it's a great part
of the game to be able to see where that end
game is.
Not everybody does a post-graduate degree
in math, but it's
tremendously inspiring for someone struggling
with differential
equations to understand on a measure as to
where this fits in with the
far larger world beyond that, to understand
the whole spectrum of
things and wholly contextualize their own
activities and see their
progress bit by bit.
Finally, fairness and transparency.
You know what everybody else is doing.
And this is really about the fact of turning
the social dynamic into
something positive.
So you have your classroom situation when
nobody knows what happens
until the results of the tests come out and
then it's all back-biting
and back-stabbing but if you can see in real
time what everybody else
is doing around you, if you can compare yourself
to them, then you have
options to collaborate.
You have options to cooperate.
You have options to learn from other people.
And one of the interesting things about games
is that people, people
really don't mind things being hard in the
long term.
They don't mind the lofty, distant pinnacles
being a long way away.
If it's completely clear how they and everybody
else are getting there,
if it's completely clear that the playing
field is level, and it's
completely clear what they need to do to get
there.
There's one very interesting innovation in
the new Super Mario Brothers
Wii -- I don't know if anybody has played
that.
But it has a very nice feature called the
Super Gauntlet -- and this
is, if you fail a level eight times in a row
or to fail it, a little
window pops up at the start and says, "Hi,
you're having difficulty
with this level.
Would you like us to take you through it?"
And if you say yes -- you have the option
-- then the computer takes
over and controls your character, takes you
through the level.
And at any moment you can interrupt that and
take over again.
But what this does -- now you might think
putting this kind of thing,
it breaks a game, it's brings [INAUDIBLE]
in fact, sort of tremendously
positive response, it's very, very well done.
Because what it does is, it recognizes the
point at which someone is
about to give up and intervenes and offers
them a route to take part in
it.
Just knowing it's there, is extraordinarily
helpful and having the option to take it out
it keeps people playing.
It stops you from losing.
And this is the thing I think that as long
as there isn't a silver
bullet or a shortcut, as long as there's not
something which negates
effort, then really the more mechanisms like
this, the better.
If it's fair for everybody and everybody is
aware what everybody else
is doing, then supporting people to keep on
the path, to keep engaged
is a sort of good for the learning environments.
You don't want to lose people.
And there are some very sophisticated ways
about keeping people engaged
and aware that the operation is fair.
Really, why is all this --
Why is all this exciting?
And I think it's exciting because we are at
the beginning of something.
We look at how far, how fast games have come
in 40 or 50 years.
And not only games.
Of course, these are lessons which are being
learned in terms of
usability and access across all sorts of vehicles.
But I think it is happened more intensely
and with more incredible
focus in the world of games than anywhere
else because of the unique
way that games tap into us as learning creatures,
and because of the
way that they allow us to rephrase failure
as success.
And I think if you look at what someone is
doing when they sit down to
use anything from a new piece of software
to using, to taking, to
learning a new job or trying to learn a new
skill or trying to get on
something, you can really start to explode
the concept of learning into
something far more just imbibing data.
You can take ownership of it.
And these kind of techniques that I think
underpin games, allow people
to be themselves differently.
They allow people to be braver.
They allow people to replace the fear and
uncertainty and lack of
engagement with the ability to make really
bold moves, to learn from
each other and the ability to take ownership
of their progress.
And I think as I said, we are at the start
of something now.
And I will be very excited indeed to see where
it goes and where it
ends.
I'm going to throw it open to questions at
this point.
I think it's probably more interesting to
start talking earlier rather
than later.
Yes?
>> I was going to say I definitely agree it
seems to be natural that
games are going to move away from a position
of not being able to fail,
because [INAUDIBLE] examples of times when
you just completely fail
like [INAUDIBLE] that but I think there's
another thing as well as not
yet succeeding, which is also like a human
desire to beat other people.
And if you're playing on say like Halo or
something like that, you play
that because like you want to defeat other
people and show superiority
over them.
I think that's another like equally important
thought as not yet
succeeding.
TOM CHATFIELD: Yeah, in terms of not -- in
addition to not yet
succeeding, there's also, you mean, this drive
to meet and compare
yourself to other people.
That's a key factor is that what you're --
>> I just mean that it's not as simple as
going from not failing to
not yet succeeding.
That's there kind of a human instinct to succeed
through defeating
other people which may be missed and there
is an aside to this.
TOM CHATFIELD: Yes, I think
so.
I think absolutely that the social context
is, is really what drives
it.
What gives it a point in one sense, there's
little point in sort of --
and I think defeating other people is a very
strong way of putting it
-- because I think that games are very good
at rephrasing that as
another one of these ongoing tasks.
So, yes, you build up your, you know, your
-- your kills in Halo, but
you never decisively beat people.
It never ends.
You're engaged in a sort of constant incremental
process of comparison.
And this, I mean, you're absolutely right.
This constant social development is what really
driving the fastest
growing games industry forward.
I think it always -- I think with most games,
comparing yourself to
other people underpins it, but I think -- I
think it's actually wrong
to think about the most powerful thing as
I beat you and I'm better
than you.
In all games, we never want the competition
to end.
In a football league, you don't say, right,
well we found out who's the
best at football.
We don't need to play football anymore.
Let's do cricket.
And we've done cricket and then we can do
golf.
And then have a play these games anymore,
we found out who's the best
at golf.
We like keeping track of these things over
time.
And interesting, there are games, the games
in which there are no
winners are ultra, ultra competitive, I think.
And you're in part competing with yourself,
partly competing with other
people.
Take Farmville, the Facebook game.
You're not killing anyone; you're not beating
anything, but you are
almost sort of fanatically trying to have
a better and better and
better list of virtual pet as it were, and
the only criteria for better
is first of all, a better than yourself, a
bit better than you were
yesterday but yet better than your friends
around you, better than your
peers on Facebook.
And so although in Halo, it happens that what
you're doing in the game
is shooting other people rather than watering
crops, you're not trying
to vanquish them as an enemy.
You're not trying to end the game, you're
not trying to end the
competition.
It would be very boring if any one of you
is overpowered could just win by breaking
the rules.
What you're trying to do is have this sort
of rolling improvement and
assessment, validated by your relations with
other people.
Does that --
>> Yeah, I guess.
TOM CHATFIELD: Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE SPEAKER]
TOM CHATFIELD: Well, I think one of the simplest
examples -- I mean,
across the world of training, it's not that
you take a company and run
the entire company along these lines.
You can take training and run it along these
lines.
For instance the military, if you look at
the U.S. military alone is
now spending $6 billion a year on games and
game-like activities.
And they set these things up.
For instance, when you are using, you know,
the first person
environment, America's Army, or when you're
using various simulations
to try and test anti-terrorism and population
location tactics, they use
precisely this kind of set up, to give people
the chance not just to do
a war game which ends in disaster, but to
revisit their mistakes and
their common errors again and again and again
and again, and try and
integrate.
In fact, they've just been coming up with
a version of SimCity Baghdad,
I think, where people who hang out there are
to be given this virtual
toy to play with, to make lots of mistakes
with, but in the context
that allows them to try stuff, because that
is the way that they learn.
So you, you can -- and you can, as it were,
get people to admit to
errors that they might otherwise conceal.
You can have someone say, well, what happens
when if I just send out
20,000 troops into the street to shoot on
sight?
You know, why not?
Let's see if that works.
And you get the people to try and do that.
And because A.) The exercise is not incredibly
expensive -- because war
games traditionally have been prohibitively,
massively, hugely
expensive.
You want to drive a tank around, you want
to fly a jet, it's going to
cost you millions of dollars an hour.
Whereas in this, you have safe repeatable
environment, you can do that again and again
and again and again.
And you can say, well, actually troops on
the streets, nobody likes me.
And I get assassinated.
Medicine is another great area, example of
this.
People looking into virtual triage tools,
for instance.
Where you can play out scenarios again and
again, and you can -- for
instance, triage is about prioritizing casualties
in order of treatment
in a disaster setting.
You can very accurately model the, the vital
signs that you would get
from people in a disaster area.
You can try out all sorts of different sequences
of treatment and
allocation of resources, see which one works.
Again, without the censure of mistakes, without
the vast expense, that
even doing active medical training with real
doctors involves.
And I think, as I say, we're only just really
beginning to see this .
But I'm talking about training and education.
And there's also I suppose the simple principle
of usability testing.
A lot of software, a lot of people are finally
starting to get their
heads around the fact, I think, in -- it's
not even vast enough,
like Microsoft is finally starting to pay
attention to the fact that
certain versions of products may be getting
less and less usable and
they needed to pare them down and have fewer
clicks.
And I think what you might call form of play
testing is actually
incremental but instrumental in arriving at
these insights and
therefore best practices.
Is that useful, yeah?
>> So as you know in World of Warcraft and
many other games are there
[INAUDIBLE]
TOM CHATFIELD: So you asked me about the,
sort of, the idea of
automation of bots to play games, and where
AI comes into all this.
And I suppose it's certainly true that one
way of rephrasing that
question would be, if you're able to take
a situation, and express that
situation as a game situation with particular
aims and rewards, that
goes a long way towards telling you how to
come up with an AI tool or
an automated tool to try and solve this situation.
And so I think there's a lot of two-way traffic
that can go on between
the idea of taking a complicated game environment
and coming up with
routines which are able to exploit that to
-- with maximum efficiency.
And the idea of rephrasing, if you like, problems,
digital problems or
computational problems or real world problems
as game set ups.
I suppose I feel that we're very, very much
at the really early days
with AI.
One of the interesting points, a lot of games
over time have had
artificial intelligence, some of which have
been thought by players to
be particularly fiendish you know, command
conquered-centered, World of
Warcraft 3, sort of people.
I mean, those are not particularly fiendish
but the lessons have always
been with those thus far I think that fully
functioning AI's haven't been terribly effective
in games, but what was been effective is looking
at play-tested, is looking at what lots of
people do, is just crunching
very large amounts of data about what people
are likely to do and
putting in sort of preprogrammed behaviors
that respond to known human
aptitudes.
So I suppose there's a bit of a -- bit of
a conflict in game science,
if you like, between the idea of trying to
come up with first
principles and artificial intelligences, which
can respond to the game
in a really effective manner, and the idea
of measuring how lots of
people play game.
And come up with ways responding to the way
that people use this game.
And so far responding to people has proved
to be a much more fertile
avenue, and using games to study human behavior
and then respond to
that has been much more fertile than if you
like using games to study
AI behavior - and then I don't -- most bots
aren't very impressive.
I can't really think of any -- any game-based
AI that really deserves
the name of AI.
And I don't think we'll be seeing that for
quite a while, actually.
Because I think that the observation of what
people do, if you like,
the use of cleverer, cleverer, cleverer observational
crowd source
tricks is really what the sort of the driving
functional force.
>> You kind of touched on it a bit talking
about AI.
For example, Halo is generally regarded as
one of the best AI computer games because
they seem to be getting smarter but their
activities are very much constrained.
And this ties into what you talking about
with simulate a [INAUDIBLE]
TOM CHATFIELD: I mean, a game would be no
good if it wasn't
constrained.
The game is about simplification.
So yes, it's absolutely about the quality
of your models.
And there are, I guess, two things really,
I think -- it's about the
quality of observation you can bring to bear.
So the people playing a game agree, and they
behave in very sort of
real ways in a game setting.
So on the one hand, you have the opportunity
to observe how real people
behave in far more complicated settings than
almost any other kind of
experiment I could think of.
And on the other hand, you have the opportunity
to measure the real
world as accurately as you possibly can, and
then try and put that data
into what -- into a model.
So for instance, I suppose with something
like you know sort of SimCity
Baghdad, you have to throw out the window
all sorts of things that you
could -- that you might want to do because
they're completely
unfeasible.
You have to try and get down to what the game
can actually do.
And I guess what it can do is not tell people
what it's going to be
like in Baghdad, but it can teach them the
kind of thinking that will
be useful to them in a city in that situation.
It can teach them what you might call system
thinking, about the way
that different variables in a system will
interact in emergent or
complex ways with each other.
And this is a very, very important way of
thinking for the 21st
century.
And it's a way that I think that has to be
learned.
So in one sense, if they're trained to adjust
variables minutely, if
they're trained not to commit the fallacies
of thinking that one
sudden, dramatic move can solve a problem,
they're trained to look to
multiple variables, and to try and just think
of the problem in front
of them as a system.
Almost to try to come up with their own mental
models of it, and that's
where the real power lies.
So games are -- games are absolutely about
modelling, but done right.
By putting a really good model in front of
a real person, you teach
them to model the world experimentally to
themselves better, and you
also teach them, I think, to try and see the
people around you.
It allows you to model the behaviors of the
people around you know to
find out things about people that you don't
necessarily -- you don't
necessarily see in day-to-day life.
You don't have the opportunity to observe
people in these kind of,
almost experimental conditions.
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE SPEAKER]
TOM CHATFIELD: I think there's a lot of -- yeah.
I think there's potential conflicts of interest
there.
But I think really we're going to see some
big eruptions in the coming
century between people, sort of, investment
in virtual property, which
they actually have no ownership rights over,
and the companies who
claim total ownership over that kind of property.
And I think you do -- you're getting to the
stage already in some games I guess Eve Online
is the most complicated example of this, where
there is-- it's reached a stage where there's
a ongoing negotiation between the players
and the people setting the rules.
Because -- I mean, it is rather a sort of
paradoxical situation that
people invest an awful lot of themselves to
into this and wish to exert
some customizable control.
But at the same time, the totality of this
whole world is owned by a
single corporate entity which at any moment
holds the keys has the right to switch you
off.
Again, this is an issue that people here will
be very familiar with in
different terms, but I think the legal structures
needed to deal with
this are nascent as well, and I think the
philosophical structures are
interestingly, I think it's by looking to
negotiations like those that
have happened in games like E, that we find
some of the most
interesting models for how this could take
place because, for a start
these communities, are totally transnational.
The goods in them are virtual goods.
But the people are real.
It's a very interesting philosophical set
of conundrums.
And I'm not sure where it's all going to end,
but I think it's going to
blow up.
You know there are going to be -- I think
there's already a couple of
test cases going on in Asia about who has
the right, rights of sort of
ownership of virtual goods, virtual characters,
virtual money.
And people, players, are beginning to assert
that they have some rights
rather than just saying well, actually, when
push comes to shove, the company owns everything
and I have no ownership in the nascence at
all.
>> I'd like to hear some practical examples
of how we would apply the
learnings that you presented to us to let's
say the UK school system in
terms of achievements -- [INAUDIBLE] based
on credits.
TOM CHATFIELD: Nice and easy question to answer.
Let's just pick one example.
Progress bars.
For instance, I see absolutely no reason why
-- why are achievements
great?
If achievements are being set by the company,
you can do two things
with achievements, you push people out of
their comfort zones and these
are sort of a positive way of trying to reach
a certain target, you're
not being penalized.
You push people out of their comfort zones,
by saying, you know there's
50 different achievements you can get in your
math's lesson.
And you know, one of these achievements is
doing ten different
equations showing you're working, one of these
achievements, is doing
sort of 25 definite integrations, and you
can think beyond the comfort zone, and also
you can get people actually to do things,
and work out that, why what they're doing
is worthwhile rather than just saying this
is good thing to do.
So you say to them for instance, well, I want
you to, you know show
your work, show your work while doing this
or do this in a particular
way.
And they will do that because they want to
take that particular box and
then in the process of doing that, they will
-- as come to a
realization through doing rather than just
being told why this is a
worthwhile thing to do.
So what I might say if is at the moment if
you are looking at marking
people, if you have very little ownership
or sense of progress, so what
about a system of each person having if you
like a sort of avatar or
electronic account where they have progress
bars on a whole selection
of different options for that class.
They can see where they are, they can see
where they want to be at the
end, they can see what it would constitute
to tick all the boxes to be
someone who achieved a GSCE.
They can have all sorts of achievements along
the way to see their
history.
It's all on the same scale.
They can see all of their colleagues and friends
on separate scales.
They can measure where they are.
They can get side achievements for doing incidental
things.
You can get bonus achievements.
You can go ahead and do more advanced work.
You get credit for trying, you get credit
for turning up, you get
rewarded constantly for doing things.
You can customize it a bit because you've
got 5 or 6 different things
you do.
So you might be the kind of person who says,
right, I want to go
straight for, you know, cubic equations. Straight
there.
I'm not going to bother with logarithms
I'm going to go and do that.
Somebody else might say, well, I want to do
some linear equations.
I just want to do 5O linear equations, and
they get rewarded for doing
that, too.
Everyone, you know, you can adapt it to be
a little, to participate in
it.
So just that use for instance for a more sophisticated,
you know, work
out the details about progress bars on the
same scales, multiple
achievements.
I think this sort of thing would be very empowering
for people and also
it would bring digital media into the classroom
is another good
way of giving people ownership of the -- of
the progress they're
making.
It has very positive connotations for people.
It can be very well marked it can say well
-- it can really be
personalized.
That would be one example.
>> Just as an immediate reaction to that I
think it's very, very
interesting but to come back to the earlier
question about World of
Warcraft [INAUDIBLE], generation of children
to sort of education
[INAUDIBLE]
TOM CHATFIELD: But the thing is, aren't people
-- I'm not -- you would
have to have a security system on this.
You would have to try to make it immune to
hacking, but for goodness
sake, look how easy it is to cheat in the
current educational set up.
I mean, the current examination set up is
almost in some, practically
defunct, in the case of the advanced math
technology.
I mean what I'm not -- I'm not saying I have
a perfect solution, but I
am saying it's, in many ways, it's an awful
lot better than what we
have now.
There were headlines recently about the, you
know, some high percentage
of people cheating on mobile phones that we
know about and accept.
People -- you could say now better, you know.
It would be a good thing to someone, not into
a bot driven to go far,
but if someone really wanted to sit there
and do lots and lots of
linear equations in order to push up their
achievement score, that's
kind of what you want out of a school.
And you know, the Nintendo brain training
is not a perfect game, but
it's a very good example of how some good
design principles can really
incentivize people, can make them want to
do it more and that's --
that's very much just a start, I think.
Because I think you need to step away from
games.
I don't want to create a brain training game
for history.
I think the principles on the line, which
are the ones I was trying to
set out, some of those.
>> Okay we'll have to leave it there.
Thank you very much.
TOM CHATFIELD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]